i'm ainsley earhart i'm charles payne
i'm martha mccallum and this is the fox
news rundown
thursday march 24th 2022 i'm john
saucier this war in ukraine has not gone
great for the russian military and now
russian president vladimir putin is
beginning to lash out at his own
officials and blame them for the
stalling ukraine putin simply won't
listen to
things he doesn't want to hear so it
could be that these guys would have
wanted to be straight up with putin and
say hey it's not going to go well but
they were scared to say that this is the
fox news rundown war on ukraine
[Music]
the british government says ukrainian
forces are carrying out successful
counter-attacks against russian units on
the outskirts of kiev maybe regaining
some lost ground a russian warship
destroyed by the ukrainian navy at a
port in berdansk so are the russian
people on board with this war or are
they starting to feel differently the
feeling that i had just before i left
on march first or second early days of
march after the invasion began
was in some ways
a bit more
anxiety written or a bit more
it was more nerve-wracking than i ever
felt when i was in the ussr in 1986
which i think kind of says a lot but but
that's me we're speaking today with fox
news senior foreign affairs
correspondent amy kellogg
about the people there i
the friends that i have the contacts
that i have
and have known over time
were
to a man and woman horrified by this
invasion they were
um worried about first of all saddened
by the thought that
ukraine was under attack but also scared
about the implications for their own
lives the sanctions came so swiftly and
it was just like one by one by one they
were thinking about aspects of their
lives that would change or be limited
and also there was a sense of shame
one
guy i interviewed the other day who has
since fled and i've heard a million
russians have fled due to this just
because they don't know what's next
said i feel like how germans must have
felt after or
even during world war ii i wonder when
it will be okay to be russian again and
i wonder when i'll stop feeling this
sense of shame let's keep it right there
in russia as we've got reports that
there's some internal bickering and
problems with vladimir putin and some of
his senior advisers some of his senior
military people as this invasion has
been really clunky and nato reports some
15 000 russian troops have been killed
during this invasion of ukraine that
matches or exceeds the number over 10
years russia spent in afghanistan what
are you hearing about what putin's
advisors are saying
well one thing i think is worth noting
is that before the war i interviewed a
lot of
kremlin friendly or close to the kremlin
analysts who said no no it's not going
to happen this is just
aggressive diplomacy but there won't be
a war half of those i would say have
hardened hardened positions and come out
strongly in defense of this war which i
i didn't expect another half
have gone completely silent and kind of
scurried away from the story with their
tail between their legs
completely so i think that's interesting
one sort of side of that pool horrified
another side really kind of upping
um
upping their support for putin in the
wake of this either out of fear or out
of some anti-western backlash which is
kind of interesting that that is taking
place too a lot of people are more
anti-western and kind of blaming things
on the west now rather than their own
government uh in terms of
any
palace intrigue
the the defense minister
sergey shoigu was not seen in public for
close to two weeks and he apparently
showed up today on state tv i mean there
was a video screen with him on it and
putin looking at it so that may have put
to rest some speculation that he was
either sidelined or um is so horrified
himself that he hasn't wanted to
associate himself more than he needs to
with the war
the other story that was interesting in
the last several days was that
reportedly to
fsb which is the
the successor to the kgb
kernels
have been put under house arrest
because
they were the ones charged with
prepping the ground for the russian
invasion in ukraine they were there
supposedly setting up networks and
recruiting people to be friendly to
russia and welcome russian troops with
flowers and that kind of thing none of
that happened so apparently two guys are
under house arrest for that and whether
i did hear rumors but i'm absolutely not
certain that these are true but it's an
interesting point to contemplate money
is involved here too so the rumor i had
heard
from someone in moscow was that
the or someone who left moscow recently
was that
that
these guys may have pocketed the money
that should have been spent winning
people over because you you know you
often buy people off it's not just
telling them hey you could have a better
life under the kremlin it's it's you
know it's about corruption so
maybe it's that or maybe it's just that
things didn't go the way putin had hoped
that they would
um
the other aspect of the story is that
i'm hearing putin simply won't listen to
things he doesn't want to hear so it
could be that these guys would have
wanted to be straight up with putin and
say hey it's not going to go well but
they were scared to say that and and
didn't and and things have gone forward
and this is the result on that note we
heard from apparently russian
intelligence analyst who told fox news
that putin's security services are in
fear of telling him anything he doesn't
want to hear they're kind of at that
point kind of going off of what you are
saying what are some of the thoughts of
these russians and retired military
russian officers who may have served
putin in the past but are seeing what's
happening now
and not liking it
yeah i think it's
there are certainly people who
will be closing ranks with him and i
don't know i can't break it down for you
what percentage of people might be
turning on him or whether there's any
any seeds of a
of a of a palace coup
or anything
of that sort underway
but i do know that
this one
russian military analyst i spoke to
yesterday said that this has gone so
badly it's gone badly on every single
level
and he said it's rare for so many things
in a war to go badly
not even russia
can do everything badly he said he was
so kind of down on the on the russian
military and his you know his own
country
in a sense and he was saying that all he
kind of knew for a while that all this
talk about russia's
vastly new and improved military in the
last several years under putin was
more hot air than reality he also said i
thought this was kind of interesting
that um the fact that these
these soldiers
a were not told about the plan
but b spent months in the winter living
in tents
on these supposed exercises that russia
kept saying were happening all around
the borders remember it was oh it's just
military exercises no we're not going to
invade ukraine these guys were camping
out in tents for two months i mean talk
about
tiring out essential forces that
clearly couldn't have been good for
anyone so there's you know there's that
going on and then the last thing i've
heard from a few different sources is
that this is not going to succeed for
the russians unless they do a mass
mobilization like the ukrainians have
done of fighting age men and that would
be so hugely unpopular in russia that it
would prob possibly be counterproductive
for them but that i've heard time and
again and it kind of makes sense i mean
they're relying on some chechens perhaps
some syrians and
young conscripts but that's that's not
going to sustain this if it's going to
continue for some time john
we're speaking today to fox news senior
foreign affairs correspondent amy
kellogg on some possible dissension
among the ranks of the russian military
and some of vladimir putin's top
advisers we'll have much more coming up
after this
a big factor in this war has been
intelligence we've spoken to many
experts on this podcast who say
big reason why ukraine is doing what
they're doing is because they have good
intelligence whether that's based on the
west whether that's the fact they have
the home field advantage whatever it is
it's working it seems to be working
in disfavor for russia can you talk
about how maybe vladimir putin gambled
on intelligence that he thought was
there but actually wasn't
well this analyst i spoke to said that
very thing yesterday he said that um
he cited
some particular
technology that's been used that's been
incredibly good and i don't have it to
hand so i won't waste your time with
fumbling around for that but he said it
was u.s intelligence that even
was seeing things underground so that
was helping
um the ukrainians immensely in this
fight immensely he also said that in
2014 when russia went in the first time
to ukraine
they russia had some is really drones
that were helping them a lot and i guess
they don't have that same capability now
but yeah that's been helping the
ukrainians um and that that been one of
the factors that has kept them going
of course there's they're
famous at this point resilience and um
and
and and resistance and
national pride
but the intelligence has been
a pretty big piece of the puzzle
apparently one last question for you i
mean i want you to look at this from
your own point of view and from a
journalist's point of view because you
were in russia when they made this new
law cracking down on reporting anything
that would contradict russian state
media that would go for any journalists
inside of russia you've left since then
russia many others have but there's been
some russian journalists who have gone
against that and are now in legal
trouble what was your feeling and what
was the feeling of your colleagues over
there when that law was happening and
when it actually passed
well a lot of the people who've left are
journalists there were there was very
very
um
there are very few there were very few
independent media outlets there is one
that remains functioning in russia
but the some of the remaining couple of
outlets were either closed down or they
just people started leaving uh in those
days because 15 years in prison is is no
joke and uh not everyone is as brave as
alex say navalny i'm certainly not
and um i i just think it's it's
frightening to think that you could be
sentenced to such a long jail term for
reporting on what the kremlin doesn't
like and the the laws are very very
strict about fake news now it's if you
want to report on the war you cannot
call it a war you have to call it a
special military operation and you can
only use information that is provided by
the ministry of defense russian ministry
of defense so there's really not much
reporting to be done at all so people
were scared
i definitely
felt a sense of unease and a lot of
people have just left i mean they've
just gone to either turkey
or georgia
or azerbaijan
uh those are or to europe if they can go
but imagine these people and of course
everyone says first thoughts with the
ukrainians because they are losing their
lives and they are losing their cities
but for russians whose bank accounts are
blocked and i'm talking about simple
people who are journalists writers i
mean i don't even know what they're
doing economically they probably can't
get their hands on money i mean they're
going abroad renting apartments and
probably can't use their credit cards i
mean
that's a logistical problem in and of
itself well we are calling it a war and
we're even calling our podcasts a war
this is the fox news rundown war on
ukraine podcast and fox news senior
foreign affairs correspondent amy
kellogg thanks for your unique insight
we it's the first time we've talked to
someone who was recently inside russia
so we appreciate the things you had to
say to us today oh thank you john
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes